[Musica]
ciao sono francesco facchinetti
ho 41 anni e sono un fallito
immagino e voi dall'altra parte della
telecamera
state pensando che cosa sta dicendo
questo perché dice che è che è un
falletto sì io sono un fallito
sì sono un fallito cronico lo so è molto
complesso per noi italiani avere a che
fare con questa parola fallito loser
perdente un po come se il nostro dna ci
spingesse a non concepire questa cosa a
sfuggire dal fallimento acquisto è che
il fallimento sia la fine della nostra
vita
la fine della nostra carriera la fine
delle nostre relazioni
la fine di tutto e invece a una bella
novità per voi
nel 95 per cento dei casi noi valiamo
passiamo la nostra vita a fallire
passiamo la nostra vita a perdere anche
se non lo vogliamo
perdiamo farli a me anche quelli che
pensiamo siano dei vincenti sono anche
loro dei falliti prendiamo la juventus
la juventus la squadra italiana con più
scudetti in assoluto penso sia forse una
delle squadre di nazioni con più
scudetti in assoluto ma in verità ha
perso sette otto finali di champions
league quindi anche loro sono dei
falliti
nessuno di noi è un predestinato pochi
nel mondo sono dei predestinati
pochi sono come valentino rossi che a
tre anni vengono messi sulla moda e
vincono per per per 40 anni e poi le
sconfitte arrivano anche per loro quindi
noi non siamo il predestinato
noi siamo dei falliti e prima impariamo
ad avere a che fare con questa parola
prima impariamo ad analizzarla prima
impariamo a trarne il massimo beneficio
dal fallimento e prima saremo dei
vincenti il fallimento la sconfitta è
l'anticamera della vittoria la verità
quindi è l'opposto di quello che ti
dicono tutti e geniale questa cosa ci
hanno insegnato per 20 30 40 50 anni a
secondo la vostra età che perdere
fallire infine su pensate solo ai
piccoli imprenditori la piccola media
impresa a chi cerca di realizzare cose
pensate solo che cosa abbiamo nella
testa io sono uno start up cronico nella
nostra destra che guarda se fallisci
quindi se tutto invece è il contrario se
fallisci è l'inizio di tutto
un po di tempo fa nei miei lunghi viaggi
amo tantissimo viaggiare mi sono trovato
a los angeles con il presidente del
cleveland basket libera da è la squadra
dove giocava lebron james per intenderci
e aironi per te mia moglie è amica di
scomodi qui siamo usciti e mangiare
insieme ea un certo punto ho parlato un
po dei miei dei miei fallimenti delle
mie sconfitte tra imprenditori lui molto
più grosso di me
il ceo le volte che mi è andata male e
soffrivo a soffrire e ogni volta che
dicevo poi il fatto che sarebbe andata
male e poi fatto che è stata una parola
malata ma le due l'idea dice che cazzo
rischio aspetta un altro ma perché se il
presidente il clima però mi stai su
[ __ ]
un altro machista e ridendo e non certo
punto mi sono stati questo è un grande
problema di voi italiani e di voi
diciamo così euro paesi non riuscite a
stigmatizzare superare la sconfitta non
riuscite ad andare oltre la sconfitta
che cosa vuol dire che rimane teli
rimane beli cioè la partita per voi non
finisce mai e non iniziare ora per cui
rimanete sempre nel limbo della della
sconfitta invece in america c'è un modo
di dire che è su 100 che fai 99 fallisci
per prenderne una
quindi il concetto è completamente
diverso quindi il concetto è devi fare
cose devi superare il limite della tua
esistenza il limite della tua vita devi
andare là nei posti dove gli altri non
arrivano per paura gli altri non
arrivano per pigrizia gli altri non
arrivano per visione ma tu devi andare
lì perché in quel posto lì dove si vince
le fasi per arrivare alla vittoria
diciamo così nel mio disegno che mi sono
fatto nella mente sono sette la prima
fase e l'innamoramento quando uno si
innamora di una cosa è pensare quella
cosa lì sia la cosa più giusta possibile
immaginabile la seconda fase la terra di
mezzo a quando arrivano i cazzi la terza
fase è il fallimento il fallimento è una
delle sette basi verso la vittoria
ok dopo il fallimento
esiste la mutazione dopo la mutazione
esiste la persona giusta al posto giusto
dopo la persona giusta al posto giusto
esiste la scalata dopo la scalata esiste
la vittoria queste fasi sono le frasi
che ci portano verso la vittoria e il
fallimento ne è una fase integrante oggi
più che mai i falliti di loser comandano
il mondo pensate questo silicon valley
loser
guardateli solo di completi loser sono
persone che probabilmente negli anni
ottanta negli anni 70 non avrebbero mai
neanche fatto entrare in un ristorante
in un bar e oggi comandano il mondo
nella musica idem e quindi non solo
diciamo nel mondo del turbo nerd dice
vabbè lì però sa bene o male sono quasi
tutti loser nella musica idem
l'artista che stream di più al mondo è
l'artista che ha venduto più biglietti
con un solo tour si chiama e gira un
loser si chiama eqseer quindi non è
stato michael jackson sono stati i pink
floyd non sono stati gli u2 non sono
stati guns'n'roses a vendere più
biglietti come solo tour ma è stato un
cantante che ha fatto un concerto solo
con la sua chitarra co questo cosa vuol
dire cosa vuol dire vuol dire che
dobbiamo andare oltre quello che è il
nostro concetto di vittoria
perché la sconfitta perché appunto il
momento in cui uno perde e fallisce in
verità può essere l'anticamera della
vittoria ciao amore tutto a posto
adesso arriva il gioco con te marmi
dieci minuti arrivo nel frattempo vedete
è arrivato anche anche mio figlio queste
sono le vere le vere vittorie della vita
e per diventare un buon padre c e papà
sai che deve perdere un sacco di volte
vi dico tutto questo perché è
fondamentale
viviamo in un'era dove ci spingono a
pensare che forse arriva primi o lo si
arriva viviamo in un'era in cui ci
spingono a pensare che dobbiamo essere
più figli di tutti viviamo e numerico ci
spingono a pensare che dobbiamo vincere
in maniera cronica nel tempo sono tutte
cazzate
vince chi ha il coraggio di perdere io
perdo ogni giorno ogni giorno cerco di
raggiungere qualcosa e non ci arrivo e
tutti noi perdiamo ogni giorno ma la
differenza sostanziale che ogni volta
che perdo per me è un anticamera della
vittoria e una di quelle fasi che vi ho
detto prima amore terra di mezzo
fallimento mutazione persona giusta al
posto giusto scalata vittoria ogni
giorno lo faccio ogni giorno mi innamoro
di qualcosa ogni giorno sono in una
terra di mezzo in cui non capisco dove
sono ogni giorno fallisco magari in una
parte del progetto non in tutto il
progetto ma fallisco ogni giorno devo
cambiare devo cambiare devo pensare che
quello che pensavo prima fosse sbagliato
ogni giorno devo trovare una persona che
mi dia un input che mi dia una visione
diversa da quella che ho
ogni giorno devo iniziare a scalare a
rendere la mia idea è il mio business
scalabile da ogni giorno devo provare a
vincere questo è quello che succede ma
se veniamo in un educazione dove quando
andavo a scuola e andavamo male ci
mettevano le facile
io andavo a scuola e mi metteva una
faccina brutta tornavo a casa da mia
mamma con la faccina brutta se viviamo
in un mondo del genere ammetto che chi è
molto complicato che è molto complicato
perché sin da piccoli abbiamo a che fare
con la sconfitta era una modalità
sbagliata completamente sbagliata cosa
credete che quando vediamo i grandi
campioni vincere vincere grandi
lottatori grandi calciatori e i grandi
sportivi vincere cosa credete che si sia
avanzati una mattina abbiamo iniziato a
vincere
no la vita ci insegna queste cose che
noi non siamo in grado di recepirlo
quando nasciamo non sappiamo camminare
non sappiamo camminare però chissà
perché
impariamo farlo e qual è la strada per
imparare a camminare e cadere e cadere
nessuno nasce ecc e della pancia e
cammina ma è solamente questo percorso
di sconfitte che ci porta la vittoria
un'altra metafora l'uomo che impara a
fare la capriola all'indietro il
backflip come a questa fase che ti porta
ad imparare a fare una cosa che nessuno
nasce imparato
scusate la licenza poetica nessuno nasce
imparato
ma bisogna mettersi lì e di imparare a
fare qualcosa che non è una cosa
naturale che non è un percorso naturale
ma lo facciamo
e c'è chi lo fa e la vittoria è
l'insieme delle sconfitte che ti hanno
portato alla consapevolezza di poter
fare qualcosa di innaturale
ok quindi chi ci ha insegnato che il
fallimento e la sconfitta siano la fine
ci ha detto esattamente l'opposto
l'opposto quindi questo messaggio che
voglio che arrivi chiaro
quando nelle vostre orecchie nelle
nostre vene nelle nostre ossa deve
rimbombare nelle vostre ossa e ogni
mattina aver voglia di perdersi aver
voglia di perdere perché tanto
perderebbe ma se lo entrata nell'ottica
di prendere la sconfitta evirarlo verso
il più piuttosto che verso il mero non
accadrà niente e ogni sconfitta ogni
livido ogni taglioni cicatrice ogni
pianta ogni delusione ogni vuoto non
sarà servito un cazzo a niente ma niente
quindi voi avrete una fase della vostra
vita totalmente calante totalmente
carente e invece la vita è un'onda è una
giostra una montagna russa e più si
scende e io ho sempre questa visione
sarò matto più si scende più si prende
velocità per salire
questa è la mia visione incendi e più
sto prendendo velocità per salire perché
all'inizio vi ho detto che sono
francesco facchinetti è solo un fallito
cronico perche mi e piu grandi successi
vengono da fallimenti in tanti mi
conoscono col nome di dj francesco ok
perché è stata diciamo la prima cosa
famosa che ho fatto e poi è stato un
disco di grande successo
ma quella storia quella canzone non è
una semplice canzone scanzonata una
canzoncina per far ballare i bambini ma
quella storia quella canzone è la mia
canzon la mia storia la storia di un
fallito e sono stato per dieci anni col
tampone oculare e mi stava fortemente
sulle palle peter pan ma alla fine se ci
pensiamo
sta un po sulle palle a tutti per
trapani 1 si veste da pagliaccio nel
senso che ci si veste con la roba
immettibile con la calzamaglia verde
tutti diciamo capi balla come il
migliore del mondo
vola sa pure volare sull isola che non
c'è ciao a tutti amici possibili e
immaginabili
ciao a tutte le ragazze possibile
immaginare l'unico nemico di peter pan è
l'unico pirata al mondo che ha paura
dell'acqua
l'unica piva dal mondo che non è cattivo
l'unico pirata al mondo che perde per
cui alla fine se ci pensiamo
capitan chino si sta simpatico peter pan
mica troppo come dicono dalle mie parti
quindi io che ho visto il mondo da un
occhio solo ma l'ho chiamato sci club
hanno chiamato guercio da tutte le cose
che fanno i bimbi ma ovviamente non
possiamo darne una colpa ai bimbi
ok io che ho vissuto il mondo e l'ho
visto il mondo da un occhio solo e vi
assicuro che è una rottura di palle
vedere il mondo da un occhio solo a un
certo punto ho detto va bene
voglio dedicare una canzone a capitan
uncino e in quella canzone e se andate a
rivedere il testo se ne avete voglia per
la prima volta capitan uncino vince
vince contro peter pan ruba la ragazza
peter pan diventa lui centrale nella
storia di peter pan e mi piace pensare
che quella canzone abbia venduto quasi
due milioni di copie sia il disco più
venduto del xxi secolo il singolo più
venduto del xxi secolo e chiedo venia
alla musica italiana
per questo per questa magia che c'è
nella canzone questa storia di un
fallimento che vedere il mondo dall
occhio solo per dieci anni è un grande
fallimento fallimento ti senti proprio
un fallito e mi piace pensare che questo
sia il motivo per cui accaduta questa
cosa perché vi voglio ricordare ancora
una volta alla fine di questa
chiacchiera tra di noi che se non
perdete che se non fallite
non succederà niente ma vi dirò ancor di
più se non riuscirete a trarre beneficio
dalla sconfitta non riuscirete a trarre
beneficio dal fallimento non succederà
niente
quindi io mi aspetto la oltre il limite
oltre al confine
al di là della barricata dove non tutti
hanno voglia
dove non tutti hanno voglia di giocare
la loro partita dove non tutti hanno
voglia di rischiare
io mi aspetto la perché è il posto dove
vivremo il resto della nostra vita
perché quello sarà il nostro
ciao a tutti grazie ciao